哇 今天台灣股市跌破失望點了
下方無底洞啊
但是我郭哲隆說話算話
我買10050說到做到
有沒有看到 我現在沒戴手錶了
我告訴你 借錢
這不是像借錢 抵押
都該拿來買0050
不是 是折折不得不啊
不能買其他的啊
不然我要買更多股票啊
我要告訴你 你買0050到時候都容易翻倍啊
韓國股市首度連兩天壟斷
還有救馬
我要再告訴你一件事情
折折之前 去年 前年
去年之前
每一次公開買台灣50
但無需吧
每次都買在基本上相對最低點
你不相信嗎
等一下我告訴你更多證據
今天台股又一度大崩2000點
直接跌破40000點啦
最後崩了1564點
收跌在4039點
投资朋友们都快撑不住啦
投资长到底该怎么办呢
难道是因为之前投资长就说过
韩股会影响台股
而这是史上第一次韩股连续两天熔断
导致台股受到牵连吗
话说回来
投资长这波最强的股票就非违心莫属啦
今天早盘还一度上涨
就算之后翻黑也只小跌2%左右
真的太抗跌啦
投资长早就预告若台股跌破4万点
哲安基金就会砸1亿进场0050
你好奇究竟投资长有没有进场0050
又买了哪些股票吗
明天美国FED利率决议
能不能让台股起死回生呢
接下来就交给我们经济日报选股冠军
单季188%的记录保持者
同时也是全台湾唯一百万粉丝
最受欢迎的分析师
國哲榮投資長
投資長好
李李
各位投資朋友大家好
唉呀
很多人你知道今天喔
我怎麼看台灣股市跌破四萬點
其實這種行情我們太想看盤
你知道嗎
是
我就準備要數錢
你說怎麼看盤
就是為什麼
因為準備要買啦
你知道什麼時候要買嗎
跌破四萬點的時候喔
馬賽一堆人在我那個
節目留言
欸 哲哲
你有沒有買
哲哲 我好期待
喔 這種就是舊粉絲
那種新粉絲
或者更沒看我節目
不知道有多厲害的
展昌 你不會騙我們吧
你有1億早退休了
我本來就說 我本來就可以退休
好不好 OK嗎
而且現在比我有錢人多很多好不好
OK 我說話算話
你看到有些網紅給你秀對戰單
都是事後給你秀
我不做這種事
可是我跟你講
我今天也沒辦法秀對戰單
但我可以給你秀那個9A9J
就是永鋒板心
是
好不好 永鋒板心
我今天就是買了1億多
好像買了
我想看
1100張
對
是
台灣50
你可以看
1100張
1100也不少啊
那個
不可能剛好同時間
又有人跟我這個券商進出嗎
沒錯
而且我等一下會跟你講價錢
好不好
我現在跟你講價錢
我先跟你講價錢
等一下你就可以查了
你現在是2點40次嘛對不對
證交所的那個
到時候的那個進出表
是3點到4點這段時間
我們大概
我看一下
我買了
好像是500
601張
不要不要不要 穿過來穿
不能秀 你現在來亂的喔
你不要害我可以
沒關係 這個至少不是損益表
對啊
喔
一一你不要挖洞給我跳
因為我太有名了
大家都會看我節目
那時候
我也答應過主管機關的
我沒有要秀這一張單
這個也不算秀啦
我要跟妳講
601張
93.45元
一一 拜託
不要挖洞給我跳
知道嗎
從一一開始
我講那個秀台灣50的東西
都不要秀出畫面來
一顆而已嗎
好
601張93.45元
就是台灣50
然後499張93.2元
好不好
大家看一下9191
看那個永鋒版新有沒有出來
好不好
OK嗎
我要跟大家講這件事情是
這這
有人一定要報應我
這這這
你股票跌那麼慘
我們環球竟然是很多人賺錢
所以我告訴你好不好
今天如果
如果我郭子龍買股票
不用申報
不會有什麼利益的什麼瓜葛
因為這個利益
因為我不能到時候變成
我借你買然後我賣股票嘛
這個一定有利益瓜葛
是
所以分譯是基本上不能買股票
就要買有那個申報很麻煩
我也不想去做這事
所以
今天如果我沒有任何限制
我過程會買環球金
好不好
我與你同在
我有一堆會員是買五六百元的
好不好
好啊
我有一堆會員是買五六百元
但是又有人買一千元左右
我得說實在話
可是這老爺的人送錢給你啊
我剛剛給你看完下來真的
欸 你手錶現在都不見了你知道嗎
喔
不要看我的毛 拜託
小孩你開玩笑
我覺得你對我最有興趣真奇怪
手錶都不見了齁
你這個就是
錢都要湊出來
是不是
是
我跟妳講現在隨便買隨便賺
我在跟你講啦
現在00981A不是每人都罵他嗎對不對
對
00981A對不對
是每人都罵他
是
很慘對不對
你看今天跌6%啦
你的ETF可以跌6%啦
最高要跌7 8 8%
我告訴你現在
你現在閉著眼睛買00981A都可以賺錢啦
欸 這我能是很好
欸 之前我可以罵你00981A的時候
你說我亂罵
現在00981跌了快40%啦
朋友你自己看啦
ETF可以暫跌啦
我告訴你反而現在可以買啊
我就這種人啦
人欺我取
我每次講這個笑話
讓你們記起來
人氣真的不要亂取
我也會出事
人氣我取
人取我語
人家不要的
我哪來講啊
今天連國具都一堆跌停板
什麼意思
我叫人家買國具啦
我買老開心你知道嗎
今天法說未啦
我國具我不要賺太多啦
我到800元就60%啦
就60%啦
買台灣50很難賺耶
現在創新高
還只能賺20%
實在是喔
我真的因為你們少賺很多耶
我如果買個環球機
我看我可能隨著變變1億賺1億
我是跟你說真的
阿哲哲
你怎麼厲害
我都是
我每一次從股災裡面發跡
我每一次
我的財富都是從股災裡面發跡
你們這些都是一些新粉絲
舊粉絲告訴他們
上一次
你們先不用回答
我在什麼時候
什麼點位
買台灣50
我看一下那時間
你们可能会吓到
赛一次
在什么时候
可以画面
什么时候
我买台湾50
各位粉丝你们回答
那你们想一下
答对有讲
好
率先第一个答对的
底下留意我们直播嘛
对不对
你拥有
馬上到時候第一份
什麼
我是不是還有書啊
哲哲
投資學
ETF投資的絕學
哪一天
你告訴我
點位大概多少就好
正負一千點
沒關係我可以接受
趕快留言
這是直播的
你現在看完的時候應該已經不是直播了
如果是晚上的話
哲哲上一次買台灣50點位是什麼時候
幾月幾號大概就好了
正負一兩天沒有關係
趕快給你們留言
送這本書還在送你那個
那個發財力
好不好
最新到時候最新的發財力
等於明年發財力
等一下喔 我看一下
趕快給你們看一下
我先跟你講一件事喔
你們不要說
因為我今天去看那個
看你股票點體板
你看得不開心
我要給你希望
大家說兩年前對不對
兩年前對不對
有沒有看到
對
有人說兩年前
什麼時候 兩年前對不對
2024年8月5號
是不是 你們這些人都是
8月5號
2024年8月5號
2020年8月5號對不對
來
對啊 2024年也對
是要給他2024年重播給我
好 很多人記得是2024年對不對
來來來 畫面給我畫面
我看一下我記什麼記錯
哎呦 2024年沒錯
等一下喔
哎呦 我看一下
2024年是8月5號沒有錯
很多人知道耶
2024年8月5號
這麼厲害
他們記得兩年前對不對
來 我們先看一下喔
哲哲在2024年8月5號
崩盤這一天有沒有看到
就這一天買台灣50對不對
那時候台灣股市點數
18000點
跌6000點
對不對
天啊
我們看一下喔
說錯了
19830點
有沒有 從24000有沒有看到
從24000
看到沒
來喔 記起來我的日子喔
24000喔
對不對
19000點
差5000點不是齁
這等於現在48000跌到38000的意思
比現在還慘
懂不懂
我買這一天就買這一天
對不對
又慘又黑的
藏的也可以放
太強了
幹的那些打的人
答對了
但沒有獎金
你說什麼
因為那不是上一次是不是
對 那不是上一次
這是2024年
這8月
好像很快我就賺到1000萬了
在8月5號的時候這一天
又長又黑的長黑K半
跌5000點喔 利不利害
等同於現在跌1萬點
哇 太厲害了
馬上彈起來喔
2020年8月 我買長250
這上一次 來 再看一下
這上上次
這2020年對不對
對
我上一次在這邊
你們看就更恐怖
欸 哪邊 哪邊 哪邊
那邊 我跟你講講
在這邊
對不對
你們看不出來對不對
上一次在
去年而已啦
2025年啦
4月11號啦
點位多少萬計
我還說多少
依依我要問你
17000 18000
17000 18000附近啦
在18000附近啦
去年18000現在呢
今天4萬點就嗨嗨叫
上一次我買18000
所以是去年 你們忘記了
我每次都買在超級低點
都是公開操作
我剛才如果刻意說謊話
差一點聽你不要怪我
刻意的說謊話
我下台去攻
這個我影片沒在刪的啦
我影片沒在刪的啦
我100多萬粉絲可以競爭
每一次都最低點喔
都相對基本上最低點很恐怖
有沒有看到
真的喔
你看看那時候股災
這邊在這邊4月11號
這邊
這邊啊
有沒有看到
跌聽板在跌聽板在跌聽板
所以你們是
忘記了還是害怕想起來
我不知道
怎麼有人會質疑我
公開操作台灣50人力呢
不要質疑
我告訴你今天就是五萬點
新粉絲拜託你們去打聽我鍋子好不好
不要看我只會打桌子好不好
是不是
看留言有沒有想起來
有沒有想起來
來大家不要敲桌子
我跟你講
厲害
而且每一次都低點喔
真的最低啊
相對最低點啊
超級低點啊
有沒有看到
是
是不是
我今天跟上哲哲
我相信哲安基金
謝謝大家啦
老天爺說你媽媽
所以今天最低點
我不能說一定的
只是前景是蠻準的
好
2022年
好像買在1萬5吧
好幾乎跌到1萬2
可是我還看就大獲全勝啊
你知道嗎
是
1萬5 1萬6
好不好
我只能跟你講
送錢給我花
再低喔
我真的要去湊錢再買
我跟你講
不會啦 這樣有 AI 啦
你知道嗎
我跟你講為什麼現在有 AI
現在為什麼 AI 我跟大家講好不好
等一下喔
電話一直煩我 我把它掛掉
看一下
我已經在裡面追東西啦我都會問那個 German 你知道嗎來 等我一下喔
等我一下喔
一些私人的東西不能給他問
你看
你看 一般手機比較好還是整理手機比較好
你覺得呢
我只是一個語言模型無法提供這方面的專注
我連續問了五次
他都會講這些
他可以跑出數字來喔
告訴答案 突然又不見了
怎麼會這樣
記憶體不足啊
又來了
什麼意思 所以你怎麼記憶體會缺
AI越用越誇張啦
它要增加營收還不簡單喔
我跟你講什麼一個月什麼六百塊
六千塊我都出啦
小孩六千塊不一定出啦
小孩一千塊你會不會買
願意
是真的 因為它真的很好用
也包含醫療
也包含你如果想要小孩
你小孩子以後家教的錢都可以省了
那這個錢真的很便宜啊
很值得
營收增加個兩倍
不就營業現金流量轉正了嗎
我說有沒有錯
沒錯
想什麼東西啊
不需要它啦
說很恐怖喔
剛才有沒有講很恐怖
你們不要記你們看一下
2025年4月11號
看一下2025年4月11號
有沒有
這個頭髮跟現在不太一樣
好轉喔
有沒有
2020年4月11號沒錯吧
沒錯
沒錯吧
我買6千萬的台灣50
看好台股看壞債券
我是真的看壞債券
你們不准我賣而已啊
誰叫我勒銷
說要賺2千萬才走
你看現在美債困在那邊
沒有關係
2025年4月11號
你們看一下看一下
在這邊沒錯吧
這沒錯吧
沒錯
恐不恐怖
很恐怖喔
從這邊這樣跌跌跌
我們拉遠一點喔
拉遠一點喔
滄海之一速有沒有看到
跟現在股市比有沒有看到
來 我們用周線來看
比較有感覺
二年 二月在這邊
在這邊啦
什麼車
太扯啦
在這邊啦
所以你們忘記了
去年最低點是17000 18000
我買在這邊相對最低點這附近啊
公開台灣50歲
老天爺送錢給我花 我就花
我沒差
誒 最好實話我也沒愛花錢
所以我沒有差
沒差
多賺的錢我再去先救護車
就這樣子
每年捐一台
每年都有一個大回檔
我們每天捐一台
今年叩答完畢了好不好
明年應該可能也有機會大回檔
記不記得
去年直播獎36000
東森的主播還在他催上面
有沒有
說直播只得敢喊
我告訴你就是5萬
今年就是上5萬
你們就不採用AI
哪個分析室
你看那些有些老頭顧的
別人頭顧很多人
到今天還想賺錢
你相信喔
你相信
我跟你講我還想參加他會員
到現在還每天給你展聽板
我還想參加他會員
你看我要參加全國比賽
你看他敢不敢
這就是老頭顧
真的我覺得這個時候要去抵制
真的我覺得新頭顧
新頭顧真的會出來
我們老師不敢說每個跡象
可是至少我們每個老師都很實在
我們也沒有要剔除
講別人
我們也不是攻擊別人的頭顧
我講是分析師
因為頭顧裡面有很多分析師
只是像我們這麼整齊的比較少一點
我們也不要攻擊別人
可是我跟你講我也發現到有些頭顧
以前看那個老師
一看就跟主力配合
我現在發現他也講大行過
滿多老師受我們影響
我覺得這樣很好
人在坐天在看
很恐怖啊
每次都買相對低低
去年是1萬7是我在買的
那個多恐怖
你不要看站子而已
站子是從2萬3跌到1萬7
你看下一天多長
下一天多長有沒有
很恐怖喔
23000跌到17000、16000點
等於現在大概46000跌到
那個36000一樣
真的
48000跌到36000
跌12000點
而且你們在講一件事喔
我有時候只是看比較遠
問你現在是不是每個人
每一個人都有財經網問
去槓桿去槓桿
韓國股市影響台灣股市
全台灣第一個講
韓國股市接下來有可能崩盤
會影響台灣股市是我國子的喔
拜託你們去比較
你相信嗎 你們相信對不對
我6月不是空手道嗎
我就怕這一天啊
怎麼知道現在才來啦
哈哈哈哈
你會記得喔
來來 你們不相信沒關係
我3 4月的時候是空手
對不對
可是你不用擔心
因為我現在買台灣50了
代表我覺得這邊就是低點了
看一下3月的時候喔
哎呀
3月18有沒有收到吧
4個月前的預告
所以有時候只能看太遠了
來 四個月前運高了
有沒有看到
你看喔
本月三萬六 下個月四萬
看起來
你看那時候
你那時候還三萬六而已
來
看一下我那時候怎麼預告
四個月前我說
韓國股市
記憶體會影響韓國股市
韓國股市會反怪
影響台灣股市
沒錯吧
是
現在全部的路邊的阿伯都知道
都是韓國記憶體影響台灣的對不對
對
沒錯吧 來
沒錯
看一下
所以我還說的
你現在
你現在股市要崩
兩個原因
記憶體要下去
美股不一定要下去
記憶體要下去比較重要
因為記憶體會牽動
美國三星跟海力士
那記憶體會牽動
韓國的三星跟海力士
三星跟海力士會影響韓國
韓國的整體的一個股價
就韓國的股價
那韓國的股價會影響台灣股價
懂不懂
然後進而影響記憶體台積電的股價
那懂我意思嗎
會影響台灣的加權指數
所以重點是記憶體
好不好啊
啊 記憶再上去呢
那我跟你講那也沒辦法啦
好不好
你看 那時候我是做空的喔
空手並向
有沒有起雞皮疙瘩啊
我跟你講我有時候看太遠啦
這是我郭總的缺點
有沒有
可是基本上我砸三錢下去
你就知道這就是長期低點了啦
你們不要看那些網紅
你們在選一下
你們現在不要忘記你們的恐懼
你只要告訴我
郭總有沒有四個月前講
韓國記憶體會影響台灣股市
而且美國股市沒有什麼瘋
是真的喔
是
現在是亞洲股市在瘋喔
好恐怖喔
四個月前哪個妹子跟你講這些話
你告訴我
我現在再跟你講一次
今年就只剩五萬點
信不信用你
All in
好不好
你有現金來
拜託
你不是我會員我不管你的
好不好
我能幫一個就跟
會員你現在有錢就給我進來
趕快跟我講
已經進來了
趕快跟我講你要多少現金
我還要再買
我國際金錢點點就買
我明天還要買
今天下午法術會還要講
你知道告訴我為什麼每一次都一個V型反轉低點我都進場
台灣50公開
你告訴我嘛
這事實啊我哪沒有給你胡扯
我100多萬粉絲我怎麼胡扯啊
全台灣第一個給你台灣股市預測今天會上4萬點也是我啊
你看一下我為什麼在這邊崩盤這樣子我買在這邊
買在這邊
我買在這邊拉遠一點你知道
殺那麼兇耶
殺個6000點耶
拉上去 這邊是1萬7耶
從1萬7以後 我買到1萬8
一路漲到5萬8耶
4萬8啊
為什麼我可以買到最低點
相對最低點
只是去年 所以剛才很多人猜錯啦
是
只猜成我在去去年年年的時候很厲害
2025年 我4月11號買進了
這2025年
請問你告訴我
為什麼前年
前年這邊
最低點
這天更漂亮是真的最低點
相對最低點
就是收盤價來看的話是最低點
我買這個又蠶又黑的長黑K半
前年
也是跌6000點
請你告訴我為什麼要強
公開收說買糖果
我今天不要跟你寫結果
你寫得不開心
你不要忘記過去的
這則我少賺很多
這則我明明就高點
我承認
我至少不會騙你
你要去相信今天還賺錢的老師
我跟你講
除非要做空
除非要空手
可是我告訴你
最後我們會賺更多
因為我們會有很多成本低
去想想看喔
三月就告訴你
記憶體會影響韓國股市
韓國股市影響台灣股市
你們看一下
你們自己看
廢半指數有很慘嗎
其實不慘啊
對不對
才剛破底而已
台灣股市是很慘嘛 對不對
那你看一下
是因為韓國股市的崩盤對不對
才影響台灣股市有沒有看到
最近很像是不是
韓國股市的崩盤你看就知道
是韓國股市的崩盤
沒錯
這很明顯吧
影響台灣股市
對
是韓國股市
韓國股市
我告訴你韓國股市5月27號
這些5月27號那些兩倍型的ETF
三星海利市
然後三星跟海力士
都是5月27號上市的
我印象沒錯的話
他們他要去槓桿
你知道從那一天買到現在的人
賠70%啦
70%
所以就是有買這產品的人
基本上一定都虧大錢
該斷都差不多了
而且好像明天後天
就要把槓桿
把他保證金給提出了
基本上全部都被砍斷了
砍完以後就會散去了
所以你看我之前就跟你講啊
我有沒有跟你講
而且我都講在前面喔
其實我的暗示有可能崩盤
可是我崩盤最厲害
不是啊這你怎麼沒賣掉
我之前也喊空手啊
可是真的還沒等到
我等四個月被你罵死啊
可是你看我等四個月
我跟你講你可能會覺得很開心喔
可是有些會員不開心
為什麼就有些不開心
今天已經崩盤了喔
我環球金還是有人賺72%
今天已經崩盤
我金才是有人賺58%
所以你每次等他回膽很累啊
是
你要做的是回膽真的很崩潰的時候
只能拉現金進去買的時候
買台灣50的時候
我只能買台灣50的時候
這個時候你要把所有現金湊出來
讓我操作
讓我幫你操作
應該說給你建議讓你操作
懂嗎
投資長
你說
聽完您這樣講
我覺得大家都已經信心滿滿
準備要all in了
真的 要all in
所以這時候是不是該來一首歌
沒錯
high一點啦 真的high一點
來小安
跟他們music 今天讓大家開心
今天是開心的日子
百握高中週年輕
你哭散的臉幹什麼
小安對不對
沒錯
要開心對不對
是
來吧
給他們
香菜蜂蜂蜂的請跟我來
等一下
沒有歌詞 不好意思
請看歌詞
好不好
再一次
3 2 1
像財富反貝的請跟我來
現在就all in快樂買起來
投資將差110050
別害怕快把我無敵大買點
真的是無敵大買點 投資長
真的 給我喝個水
是
我也蠻累 也蠻激動
其實我是很平常心耶
其實我跟你講
當分析師有時候不一定只要賺比較多
我跟你講 我今天隨便買個環球金
就算B等已經買00981A也會賺
我跟你講為什麼你知道嗎
很有可能00981A
我先給你預告喔
你們看喔 只要00981A
我們用00981A
所以姚慈晶姆我相信他一定認識我啦
好不好
因為我這麼紅
而且我有時候覺得我在批評他
我們剛才最高點的時候大概是32.73
對不對 沒錯吧 對
32.73嘛 好
我們現在今天是23.85好了
23.2好了
23.2記起來喔
32.73除以
23.2
23.2嘛對不對
對
同學沒有他到高點可以展40%
1.41嘛
是
所以他只要創新高就一定可以賺40%
所以台灣股市有可能還沒有5萬點
他已經先創新高了
賺40%好
這回到高點嘛對不對 沒錯吧
是
這邊啊 回到這高點了對不對
我們對過去
從現在開始回到這高點
41%
現在有點歪 同樣的高點41%
記起來
台灣50
回到高點真的賺很少
112到93.7
來我們記住91.8好了
112.3就是最高點 就是48000的時候處理多少 進多少91.891.8元我今天本來要掛我今天本來掛92.1你知道嗎殺下去 我想說怎麼還沒有殺
因為那時候10點多就準備要買
那一直有人催我
說整整你要不要買
我很怕殺下去
馬上彈4萬點你知道嗎
彈到4萬一你知道嗎
所以馬上我就去追
追到什麼
我看說93.2嘛是不是
是不是 依依
差不多
好93.2 93.3嘛
差不多那個價錢
我本來要掛92.1
是因為我怕我們買不到4萬點的台灣50
好扯遠的
就是112.3除以91.8
就是今天的最低點
你看喔
它反彈到最高點才22%
同樣回到跌
所以現在股票跌太少
也很麻煩
我反正希望跌多
跌多反彈到怎麼樣
原本的高點的時候
不好意思喔
到什麼時候
我剛才說什麼
二級啊
21啊對不對
是
是不是21
沒錯嘛
應該是齁
你們都沒關係齁
我剛記得是21%
好 才賺21%
剛才是一個多少 41%
對
所以我現在00981
大家痛苦的時候
我叫你們不要買00981
你不理我
現在叫你買00981
你幹嘛
我反而覺得可以
可是缺點是什麼
長期績效還是台灣50
會贏00981
怎麼辦
我再跟你進階
這免費的喔
不過你自己要操作喔
等00981A真的創新高的時候
你再換台灣50就好了
都準備創新高
其實這是最好的操作啦
那好難喔
所以你還是得找我啊
是啊
其實等0.081 為什麼
這一段 這也是喔
來喔
沒關係 我去教你們
沒關係 聽得懂 聽得懂喔
這個跟我說過也沒關係
可是我這個就是好人
等0.081 創新高的時候對不對
對不對
對
然後
台灣50 怎麼樣
那時候也會接近新高
對不對
可是0050接近
0050接近新高的時候
理論上是這樣的
真是談得更快
這樣的時候
00981A一定談比較快
為什麼
因為00981A一堆國趣啊
到現在都沒出掉
然後昨天出的是台積電
很多輸回啊
00981A等似同別的ETF都可以
你不要明天看了
哇 哲哲說00981A不錯
你最敢買的是股票
好不好
我只說你亂買都可以
他會反彈很快
因為它跌很深
它反彈高點的41%
懂嗎
可是等到高點的時候
你要換台灣50
所以我單初跟他說
981A
最好不要買
我是有個前提
如果你不懂進出
那就不要買
如果你懂進出
有時候譬如順勢盤
我進去創新高
那你要買0.981A
可是今天要崩盤的
你981A要換掉
因為會跌得很恐怖
有時候跌得比個股一樣
40%不是跟個股差不多
對啊
那你買股票就好啦
這樣有什麼道理
這樣懂嗎
這懂我的邏輯吧
可是強反彈的時候
哎呀 你不知道買什麼
那這種主動型ETF
績效比較好的可以
因為他通常結很兇
懂不懂
唉
真的沒有這麼好的老師啦
唉呀
來喔 我們剛才今天播兩個重播
這個是去年的1萬7000點的重播
沒有錯吧
對
1萬7000
你們忘記了好對不對
去年有1萬7000對不對
我買了1萬7000啦
差不多前年
我買了1萬6000
1萬9000啦
去年1萬7000 8000
前年還1萬9000
都跌6000點的時候崩潰
我這次還忍到跌8000點
而且這次有AI你怕什麼
然後我還有一個重播
我告訴你
韓國記憶體會影響韓國股市
進行影響台灣股市
分析師有本事
要像我一樣提前告訴你
只是這個很難抓
你懂嗎
這真的很難抓
可我不在乎啦
我這些為你到時候績效
我跟你講環球金我還是覺得2000元
今年有機會
記得我這句話好不好
好不好
等一下現在三點多了
我等一下請四瑤看一下
你們也幫我看一下
就是證交所什麼時候
那個券三進出
是
我不給你對戰單
但是你可以從券三進出裡面
知道怎麼可能這家券三
今天突然多了1100張的
而且符合我剛才講的價格對不對
沒錯吧
沒錯
我剛才講的價格是
93.45601張
601張
然後
那個
93.2是499張
OK
騙不了人
來
那我們來看一下我們大家玩有的一個互動
來你們看一下喔
我今天要給你們信心啊
所以不好意思
我沒有講單獨股票
因為講單獨股票沒有用
全群覆沒
有一個人
我講一下為什麼紅海最強好不好
也告訴你這為什麼不是股災好不好
其實今天節目蠻精彩的
分析師指符者者
這難人說到說到
我跟你講
記得現在自責心高氣要這樣子
記得 拜託
來
你的美財怎麼辦
就犯著辦怎麼辦
怎麼辦怎麼辦 我也很討厭他
你們可以100%通過
無意表決說我不用退休嗎
不然我現在賣掉 我要退出股市耶
不要
哲哲0050公開勝率是100%啦
沒有錯啦 過去啦
過去不代表未來啦
不過這次我有很信心啦
一年一頭之長 百年國中 謝謝大家
哲哲說話說話話不是已經第一次了
我怎麼好奇整整有辦法一下子拿出E
有沒有看到
那個手錶最近都不見了
不見了
湊錢啊
你說是不是
是不是早知道
早知道
你有沒有發現到
我如果跟大家講說不要槓桿的時候
我就預期
是
可是那個很難抓
我就再講一次
我今天環球金還是有賺70 80%
那我要一輩子都休息嗎
也是很難抓
所以你要做的是
你不要
我那時候跟他講
我那時候有很多人說AI跑跑跑跑
我就殘掉囉
我絕對是今年講過最多次的
你們告訴我哪個分析師
有比我多次說你們不要借錢
不要槓桿
拜託你去參加會員
不會喔 是跟你講這些話啦
說這些話收不到會員啦
我根本不在乎
你基本上摺粉就是覺得少賺錢
甚至有些人覺得可能最近賠錢
可是不會有人這樣抬出去中
你懂嗎
是
不會抬出去
我連贈二我都叫你不要買
連0050贈二都叫你不要買
然後我們要好不好
我跟大家講
好 來
來
這我看了一年七年加入會員
喔你聰明喔
你聰明喔
好不好
981A展廳跟政二很接近
可是至少981A喔
不是槓桿
只要槓桿我就不喜歡
就很簡單
你有沒有看到
你們以前問我50政二
我就說不要
你是槓桿嗎
現在不是海力士政二
一樣啊
是不是
喔OK
不買政二帳那麼多
我就不喜歡
我可以買政二
我覺得抓低點政二是很好
但我是一個公眾人物
我沒有強調誰
我知道我們公司其他老師
其他老師也會偶買這個
只是我的粉絲是全台灣最多
我有更大的
我有更大的公眾的利益要符合
你懂嗎
我要符合大家
你對我的一個期望
我不敢說什麼
哎呀我開車有時候會不會闖黃燈
或許有時候有
可是至少投資這方面
我要一定要維持我的人設
而且我覺得不是故意維持人設
因為我覺得100格裡面
100格裡面
我記得沒有錯的話
好像是
我突然想起來為什麼
很多人說為什麼不用桿桿你知道嗎
是
我記得好像
以前我有買一檔股票基亞
這個大概15年前的事情
我不知道要不要說
十幾年前
完全至少十年前的事情
那檔股票就是解盲失敗了
然後解盲失敗的時候
19根跌停板我記得
因為通常20根跌停板就會嚇死了
19根跌停板你知道嗎
我在電視節目上我講得很大聲
你看我賣高點
你知道嗎
我這故事我永遠都記得
沒關係
那我也很難過的是
我在節目上說
我看我賣高點
你看這減盤就有問題嘛
我買基亞
所以為什麼現在也不買生技股
你會發現嗎
可是有人會有粉絲跟我講
粉絲說
哲哲我只有看你節目有推薦
但是我後面沒有看你節目了
基亞現在19根點體版怎麼辦
我嘴巴是可以罵他說
那不關我的事
因為你只看一半而已
可是我很難過啊
說不定你本來就不是我忠實的粉絲
你只是要牽托我耶
可是我聽得難過
因為我曾經真的有介紹過基亞
那只是後面我把它出掉 你沒看
你怪我 基本上你不能怪我
可是我也是有內疚 你知道嗎
所以從那個時候我就知道
我有公眾形象
你聽懂我還說什麼嗎
所以今天來了
政二我認為99.9%
績銷比台灣50好
你知道嗎
可是但他在崩盤在崩盤呢
台灣
50政二這個ETF
你看看是
大家有想過嗎
我買這麼穩
欸 台灣50增2就像
那個三星海力是真的
就像台積電增2一樣啊
是不是
那台積電增2是不是也像台灣50增2一樣
某種方面也像啊
對
因為台灣50也是台積電的形狀啊
我講的沒有錯吧
有點像
這麼穩的都可以搞到一堆人斷頭
跌70%
你怎麼會不覺得台灣50增2
萬一呢
特例中特例呢
韓國股市那些散戶會覺得
會覺得三星海力是這麼穩的股票
三星政二會跌那麼慘嗎
你們也沒有經歷過台灣50政二跌那麼慘
台灣50政二沒有經過2008年金融海嘯
腰斬在腰斬的例子
沒有經歷過
你們都事後看而已
為什麼不推薦台灣50政二
你看我突然想到
我突然覺得
我怎麼就記得一個很難過的故事
基亞我公開推薦賺很多
我出掉了
還是有人怪我
今天台灣50政二
我跟你講我叫你買
然後我也出掉了
你可能還在耗著上面走
等到你斷頭你怪我
我承擔不起
我這些錢我寧願不賺
我可以賺很多啊
本來就是如果我要抓低膽
一定是買台灣50真的啊
我抓V型反轉台灣50真的
一定賺得更多啊
懂我意思嗎
所以謝謝你們提醒我
為什麼我不講這些東西啦
我覺得人在多天看
那不代表其他分信師不好
我有我的社會義務責任
我是告訴大家好不好
就是跟大家講這些東西
那也是因為這些東西
你會覺得看起來很年輕
但我經歷過我股市30年
我單分是20年
所以為什麼我國劇
笑看國劇
你懂嗎
是
國劇以前好像要下市
國劇公司就喜歡買
就喜歡買什麼
你有沒有想過陳代明
為什麼今天法座的不出現
一定有人問他你要不要賣
他如果講不賣
那以後能賣嗎
是
他如果講不賣以後能賣嗎
我是他我就不出現
懂嗎
他們聽你看你癢癢癢
我只講實在話
我講話很實在
可是他是
厲害的公司領導人
只是喜歡玩資本遊戲而已
你懂不懂
減資 增資 減資 減資 減資
應該所有善事會股票他最喜歡玩
你懂不懂
他一度要下市了 你知道嗎
是被政府拒絕的
這這些故事誰能跟你講這些東西
經歷過20年了 好不好
這個啦
一萬人今天就第一點了
今天在線人數穿新高
你看
總算要一萬人 剛才一萬人嗎
九千九啦 測個一萬人啦 好不好
答案三點多好不好
所以今天股票都不用幹
為什麼
亂跌一通神經病
我看
現在跌我看
就是很簡單
環球金好開心
1000多塊錢的貴
864元
我拜託你們買一下好不好
我就要分散
你不要只買一膽
好不好
這群年呢
群年也跌很兇
群年也可以買
你現在要跌
你就存那種跌40%以上了
這已經是股災型了
你知道嗎
商務法則通常是可以買的
跌40%以上就基優股的
精彩
也可以買
金財的缺點是跌不夠多
是
我還是有賺喔
我能夠為你還是有賺喔
賺58%喔
我是選比較低的成本啦
因為有些人可能多次進出
像環球金有多次進出的
好不好
OK嗎
有550又有730的吧
730以後好像變1000元左右買的
買很多批
選比較低的
金財你看又有58.7
選今天比較高的價位
那我們看一下
金財我們看一下
假設今天是418元
出279元
好不好
剛講到基亞故事就很難過
所以你們
所以有些東西
有些東西是塑造我的一個文化啦
好不好
所以我覺得就像五週之曜一樣
先求不三生再求了下
好不好
所以為什麼
我說我每天很認真工作
我就不喜歡有些
到今天你還跟你講展廳吧
佩服
那你應該是全國冠軍紀錄保持者
不可能的啦
不要騙自己啦
好不好
那這一回看出來什麼叫新頭顧
舊頭顧的差別
我有沒有要攻擊誰
我只是攻擊一個現象
我認為那些現象
那些分析是至少會改進的
也沒什麼不好
好不好
我們要攻擊別人
絕對不會去攻擊別人
不需要
因為我也討厭別人亂攻擊我
要把279.5我看多少你幫我看一下講那個基亞故事有點難過279.5 除以418.5 來讓你看一下
279.5 除以418.5
按錯了 心都亂了
你看 這個還34%
一堆股票40%
你看 這才34%
6488環球金 你看
1600嘛 一半多少
一半是800就快800啦
好不好
我現在最先
為什麼我是2327
我強反彈啊
是不是
我不要他1200啊
我到800就好了
是
而且你看我對瑤瓷金母多好
我對00981A多好
00981A的成本在470元附近
我幫他
我幫他們護盤耶
我跟你講
不是我吃他們豆腐喔
好不好
我還買得比他們高一點點
可是我買得至少不會很痛苦
也不能這樣講
我買得很漂亮
我賣在六七百元嘛 對不對
我賺一百% 走啊 對不對
是
這是在買 有進有出喔
好不好
這跟大家講 好不好
夜盤噴
只是我想買微信 可是大家都沒跌
我跟你講喔
你現在可以買兩種
我覺得你可以分到四個股票
四檔股票兩檔很強的股票
是
兩檔本來很強 但很慘的股票
什麼意思
比如說你可以買精彩 微信
不要講完了
你不參考會 我不跟你講的
頭長不能再說了
不講
你們不要省小錢花大錢好不好
是不是
既然這些什麼賺的賠的都夠了
你他要會餘幾十年了好不好
OK嗎
責治緣還在嗎
在在在在在在在
可是治緣不是算AI主力
現在還沒到ASIC的晶片題材
吃早會好不好
玩得突然愛扯扯
以前不愛我
人在做天在看好不好
來
正貨 期貨是正價差
而且正貨 以前正貨績效好是因為
以前譬如說台灣股市4萬點對不對
以前期貨
比如說到六七月的時候會
以前都會填權席
然後以前用正價差
現在期貨有時候會逆價差
所以那個正二很難說
你懂得聽得懂嗎
以後期貨的環境不一樣
你不一定買正二會賺很多
先跟大家講
期貨的槓桿績效不是兩倍
大概是1.5 1.6
平均經過這個實驗
我講太多我怕你聽不懂
你一聽就知道
只能轉眼好不好
OK嗎
這跟大家講
參加我會員有30年的投資經驗
還有一些台大政大的
會計師的
好不好分析師的
幫你做一個研究後盾
怕什麼
而且我跟妳講的
連續三年
都買了低點
今年也不知道
明天看就知道了好不好
都買一個相對超級低點
好不好 OK嗎
而且我都預告喔
我對你們很好
我都預告
每次是來了
我去買
我都預告喔
我對你們很好
去年前都預告喔
去年還在1萬7萬而已
所以現在回到4萬點以下
很正散啦好不好
小盤多少
夜盤賺多少點
再疊下去怎麼辦
0050成本已經比股價高了
什麼意思
來我們看一下
夜盤跌300點
怎麼辦啦
又跌300點
跌200點
我是現在已經應該說
應該是他有正價差喔
是40600點喔
如果明天拉到40600點
我就賺600點喔
只說老天爺收錢給我花
那怎麼辦
再疊呢
再疊我再去湊錢
不要了啦好不好
這樣子也會有點緊好不好
手錶就最近都不見了
哎
趕快來找我啦
這怎麼辦
你不要四萬五再找我啊
這就不是白碟了
是不是
OK
黃沿建設買國具
好像買1200嘛
黃沿建設應該來找我參加會員才對啊
哈哈哈哈
來來
我以為四萬一已經好小價格了
我還以為恩哥就說我啦
說者只能買四萬點
說沒成一啦
根本不打算進場
你看喔 我買什麼都被人家罵
這個龔志斌是我們很熟的朋友啦
很熟粉絲啦
他以為我四萬點是好小
沒有發現四萬點
喔 殺下去把他拉起來
是
都預告
沒有 我不是好小
我就覺得這個點位
我要買一個
我問你啊
如果我四萬五
跌到四千次
我買這個就沒有V轉的感覺嘛
對
可是如果我四萬八
跌到四萬點一下
然後我買得很漂亮
然後又有V轉感覺
你又覺得我照神
哇 而且這個神是真的神喔
好不好
四條出來了沒啦 趕快
我們先趕快趁到那個
來來來來
來來有出來了
3.18分等我一下
現在幾分了
24分
0050我們看一下喔
0050喔
查一下喔
這是買賣日報查詢表
你自己看一下喔
證交所的買賣日報查詢好不好
我把它放大了
因為不然你們看不懂
Q
查一下查一下沒關係
跟我一起
Q88
UY
我剛好說
你小孩你記起來沒
我們查
按一下我查一下
來 我們唸一下喔
來喔
那個93.45是601張
那個Lily以後你要拿個筆
要記一下
499是93.2
好不好
我們剛剛講過嘛對不對
499張是93.2元
0.050喔
看一下喔
這個是證交所網站
不可能造假吧
好不好
因為我們要符合
因為我要符合
因為我太紅了
很多人關切我
記得喔
分析師不太能買股票
可是可以買ETF
不要再鬧
ETF
為什麼可以買ETF
因為一天五不會有利益的那個瓜葛你知道嗎
這樣怎麼知道
不會有利益的糾結
每一天五誰能操縱他
這樣怎麼知道
我操縱才晶電喔
我操縱才晶電是不是
好 來
看一下喔
好 按囉 按囉 按囉
欸 怎麼不行
可以拿了
欸 不行
氣死了
是淡掉是不是啊
我沒有按錯啊 為什麼
等一下等一下
要哭哭了
等一下 我看一下 我把它縮小
先縮小一下
T G 9 Y H
查詢
它淡掉對不對
是不是要淡掉 你現在這裡不能查
是不是太多人都在查
那個獎沒錯啊
因為這個100多萬粉絲
今天線上就1萬多人啊
就像是搶票一樣
會當機
有可能有可能淡掉
資料太多了 現在才能看到
他要下載檔案啦
下載 下載
下載有沒有 下載
下載050有沒有到
用下載
思想說要下載有沒有到
用下載 可能今天太多人了
開啟檔案
來囉
這不好意思用下載檔案了喔
然後思想說需要多少
61735跟61760
你看一下
61735就是61760對不對
有沒有
61735有沒有看到
永豐有沒有看到
好我們放大放大
我剛說922.2嘛
沒錯吧對不對
這一次我表不好啊
93.2
那怎麼92.2
看不懂
看到93.2啦
是要記錯了
93.2有沒有看到
這邊有人買
看不懂耶
這是最上面
等一下喔
買進股市有沒有看到
買進股數
賣出股市
買進買進
賣出
9.1段
6.1段
好複雜喔
是喔
可不可以
現在真的還不能查嗎
你們自己查一下好不好
這不重要好不好
好 我查我查我查我查
我怕你們覺得好像我騙你們一樣
93.2是不是
對
欸你看93.2是不是這邊買很多張
這等於
這是我們放大
個十百千萬
這等於是買那個
523嘛 沒錯吧
是不是
我跟妳說93.2買多少張
499吧
代表有人買一個
我猜是不是有人偷跟我單啊
永鋒這個券商
你看這個價位是不是特別多啊
是
這價位特別多嘛對不對
對
93.2
你看到嗎
93.45
你看看這個券商
有沒有看到
放大放大
這邊特別多有沒有看到
有
這沒錯吧
沒錯
這是永鋒的
永鋒的喔
9A9J的券商喔
你看一下喔
永鋒版新嘛對不對
93.45600
拉遠
不好意思
我把它拉近
93.45有至少613張
因为是613311股
那是等同于6133张
我说我刚才至少买了601
对不对
没错吧
所以要大于它
有人跟我买同一个价位
93.2
有没有看到
你自己看
最多的数字
自己看一下
最多股是一个
集中在93.2
有没有看到
跟93.45
有沒有錯
沒錯吧
沒錯
這邊哪邊最多
93.2
93.4有沒有看到
這邊哪邊最多
93.2有沒有看到
都是永鋒版新的
你看 往左看
都是9A9J永鋒版新的
沒錯吧
沒錯
9A9J
聽不了人喔
93.2有沒有看到
這邊最多張
至少大於499
所以測驗成功了
好不好
這版就成功
拜託
這個如果不成功
我那個美債可以耗在那邊
這有什麼騙你的好不好
這不做沒有把握的事情
講話你看300多點啦
有沒有看到
今天剩幾分鐘
果股要多一點
這叫做系統性的中盤
很多時候以前解盤解不重要
怎麼不重要這很重要啊
你看就韓國股市不解的能行嗎
現在來給你解韓國股市有用嗎
四個月前我就講韓國股市
會影響台灣股市
那時候我就大概知道泡沫了
國具我今天反而買好不好
那科我走掉了
我考慮也買 好不好
我考慮奶雅科確定是跌太少
我寧願買環球金啦
或者是82997年
有可能以後最後還是奶雅科先創新高
沒關係 我喜歡買跌升的 好不好
我這波計較那麼好
也是因為買跌升的股票
就是買低檔的股票
你看紅海為什麼
我明天留個紅海科的書
你知道紅海有什麼基本上沒跌嗎
紅海沒跌跟台積電沒什麼跌
是一樣的意義 什麼意思
現在從頭到尾
你不要說台積電跌很多
台積電跌差不多
台積電沒跌很多
紅海跟台積電媒體的原因是因為
是因為現在修正本益比
都是那些外資亂喊什麼60倍本益比
懂不懂
都先修正那些60倍本益比的國具
但懂不懂
所以喔
從紅海告訴你
告訴你只是修正本益比
因為紅海本益比不到15倍
不要開玩笑了
懂嗎
台積電本益比
明年來看話
不到20倍
不要開玩笑
懂不懂
所以只在修正本益比
所以AI不是泡沫
記得我這句話
這邏輯很重要
不懂我明天要跟你講
一堆股票我今天用力買了
先買國去
我買1億3.50
上次買是最低點
相對最低點
沒錯吧
沒錯
這上次最低點也是18000
去年前年都是那個V星翻轉
你去想看
你今天有沒有信心的
趕快來加入我韓練啦
趕快來今天直播人數
一萬多人見證我真的有買啦
好不好
OK嗎
券商進出
你再自己看一下
9A9J大寫好不好
遠風版新的
自己看我剛剛那個價位
我講的重複很多次
所以這不是重點
你看我數淘汰票幹嘛
你跟我一起數淘汰票
比較有感覺的
到時候我還是要捐出救護車啦
看怎麼樣啦
歡迎來臨小型
080668085
或是加我來私訊我
不論對我或是錯
折折一切一切
預發前面
無敵到滿點
一年一次的折折
臺灣五時奇蹟進場啦
這一次要不要再把握住
你趕快來
明天是你可能最好的買點
你趕快跟我一起來賺大錢
加入我們行店
趕快來我私訊我說
折折會不會多少
我捷緊所來幫你賺大錢
今年五萬點以上見
謝謝我
記得之後你會謝謝我
拜拜
0800 66 8085
谢谢大家